[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts keeper of keys and
grounds
rubius hagrid and his role at hogwarts
school
of witchcraft and wizardry more
specifically we're going to be deep
diving into his role
to uncover what he actually did day to
day
what were his tasks responsibilities
before becoming a hogwarts employee
hagrid first went to the school as a
student he began his studies in the year
just two years after voldemort himself
and initially proved to be quite
promising young wizard however
unfortunately for hagrid
voldemort or tom riddle attending the
school meant that the school was in a
bit of a state of chaos
this was because tom had opened up the
chamber of secrets
releasing the basilisk within leading to
the petrification of students
unable to point the finger at anyone
else hagrid was eventually blamed for
the attacks on the students
as he was known to have a pet
acromantula named aragog
which headmaster armando dippit felt was
responsible
hagrid was subsequently expelled however
he was allowed to continue working at
the school
at the request of albus dumbledore it
was in the year 1943
that hagrid began his formal training
for the position of gamekeeper
at hogwarts at that time working under
the existing
senior gamekeeper ogg ogg worked his
game keeper before hagrid and we know
that there was some overlap because in
the text
molly weasley reminisced about ogg
working at hogwarts
mrs weasley was intrigued by the
whomping willow which had been planted
after she had left school
and reminisced at length about the game
keeper before hagrid
a man called ogg molly would have begun
studying at the school in the early
1960s
nearly 20 years after hagrid's expulsion
this time frame would have put hagrid in
his 30s which means that he was likely a
junior game keeper for quite some time
so what
you might ask are the actual
responsibilities of a game keeper
besides raising gigantic animals and
sitting around the fire in his hut
what did hagrid get up to well as it
turns out quite a lot
first and foremost hagrid was
responsible for looking after
all of the school's keys true i haven't
introduced myself
rubius hagrid keeper of keys and grounds
at hogwarts
another one of hagrid's large
responsibilities was doing odds and ends
for dumbledore
tasks related to official hogwarts
business
he usually gets me to do important stuff
for him he was also responsible for
escorting first-year students on the
boats to the castle
helping to familiarize them with their
new territory hagrid of course
was still fighting his way across the
lake with the first years
hagrid was certainly a man who wasn't
short of things to do
and in addition to the above tasks it
has been expressed that he also
tended to the hogwarts gardens likely
under the guidance of pomona sprout
looked after magical beasts on the
school grounds looked after matas in the
forbidden forest
defrosting the school's brooms during
winter bringing 12 christmas trees to
the great hall during december
and even growing the pumpkins for the
halloween feast in the small vegetable
patch behind hagrid's house
were a dozen of the largest pumpkins
harry had ever seen each with the size
of a large boulder
so as you can see hagrid had plenty to
keep him occupied
i imagine that while he was working
under ogg ogg would have been more
responsible for the
larger tasks like going on official
hogwarts business
where hagrid the junior games keeper
would been more in charge of actually
groundskeeping and that's it for this
video did you guys ever wonder what
hagrid actually did
day in and day out did you know about
ogg let me know in the comment section
below until next time if you want to
know what a man's like
take a good look at how he treats his
inferiors not his equals
[Music]
you